oh and huge congratulations I absolutely
adore your movie thank you great thank
you all right Jason I'm coming your way
first because I was reading in our
production notes about how big draw for
you with this project was getting the
opportunity to have a front row seat to
seeing Ben direct so now having had the
experience what is something about him
as a director and leader on set that
makes him stand out and maybe something
that you even back pocketed that you'd
like to apply to one of your directing
gigs in the future no I was surprised
how bad he was
um it was you know you wouldn't think it
you know best picture and all that stuff
and then just garbage on the set
um but he's well surrounded um and
listen he's nodding everybody can tell
I'm surprised it hasn't gotten out yet
but um we powered through we had a great
script to work from and um everything
seemed to work out okay our press notes
is start to finish people praising Ben
and specifically his instinct to always
trust the people he works with and bring
the most out of the material together
yeah
yeah we're the honest ones we gotta we
gotta be honest here we're making news
today yep all right this is my headline
obviously Ben Affleck a terrible
director who made a great movie Garbage
two thumbs down I'm curious to see how
far you push it with the lies on this
one Chris so you on the other end have
worked with Ben two times even after
having worked with him on Argo and live
by night what is something he did on the
set of air that even you didn't expect
he was capable of
um I guess he was even more confident
maybe even more relaxed he was
surrounded by uh his best friend and so
many of his friends he's worked with
Jason before he says that he's always
wanted to work with Viola and Chris
Tucker I I've done three movies with him
Matt Mayers worked with him before so
Bob Richardson shot this he shot lived
by Night the list goes on so he was it
was very much like a family affair
um he seemed to be having a blast and
and and and that was contagious so so
were we I was I was learning about that
um this is a little bit of a big serious
question for you but one of my favorite
parts of this movie is how it's mainly
about someone who chooses uh you know
deeply authentic passion over what some
might deem the smarter business move so
over the course of your careers can you
give me an example of a time when
someone recognized you know your vision
your passion and your heart over what
might be the better business or
financial decision and they believed in
something that you wanted to do and you
got to do it and it turned out great for
it and
poor man uh I don't know about that
um I mean I guess a real an easy one
would be like if I said oh I want to
want to go do this Equity waiver show uh
you know some small little theater job
at the expense of doing uh like a a big
paycheck film I I've never
never had one of those to to have to
battle between uh fortunately I don't
get a lot of choices you know I
basically do I'll take what I'm getting
you know and every once in a while uh it
works out
um I think it's oh I think it's like
almost every other day at least for me
in this business you know where you're
just doing this doing what we what we do
you're constantly being told no or you
can't or you know so so whether you're
giving it to yourself or you're looking
at your loved ones going you know go go
and it's it's it's pretty much an
everyday kind of um
uh maze
um I don't know if I can spot one
specifically but uh
but it's consistent for what it's worth
I think you're both navigating that maze
well it led you here air is fantastic
thanks for your time today and
congratulations again
thank you so much nice to meet you